So that's Android design in a nutshell.
We hope you've learned a lot.
We started with lesson one.
A crash course in Android
design fundamentals.
>> In lesson two,
we learned about tangible surfaces.
How they establish a clear
visual hierarchy and
make your UIs immediately
comprehensible.
In lesson three, we learned how to
apply the principles of space, color,
typography and imagery to let
your brand shine through and
make your app's content look beautiful.
>> In lesson four, we discussed how
deliberate meaningful motion helps to
tell your app's story and
make it feel alive.
>> And in this lesson, we learned how
to adapt our designs to the different
screens your users have in their lives.
Now go and
design the next great app for Android.
Using the techniques in this course,
you're sure to build something
delightful and awesome.
We can't wait to see
what you come up with.